merci d'être avec nous Eric et nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure sénateur socialiste des
Landes vous êtes vice-président de la
délégation sénatoriale aux collectivités
territoriales et à la décentralisation
et on va commencer à en parlant de ces
violences d'abord un peu plus
généralement on va parler des violences
envers les élus on a vu le maire des
missionnaire de Saint-Brévin on a vu
cette infirmière qui a été assassiné à
Reims les policiers trois policiers qui
ont été tués à Roubaix par un chauffard
Emmanuel Macron hier on conseille des
ministres à parler de des civilisations
vous partagez ces mots
ce qu'il faut surtout pas
surréagir à des événements qui sont
tragiques parce que ça c'est une réalité
pour les familles qui sont pour les
familles qui sont concernées je pense
également aux gendarmes policier qui ont
été fortement impactés ces derniers
temps meurtriers dans leur chair et puis
mort décédé pour pour certains on l'a vu
encore à Roubaix je pense à ce qui s'est
passé également dans mon département
récemment où il y a eu aussi un accident
tragique qui a concerné des gendarmes
après il faut pas se il y a des
tendances il y a des tendances lourdes
qui sont pas celles de des civilisations
il y a des faits graves parfois et
d'effets tragiques on le voit maintenant
on peut pas on peut pas dire que partout
dans la société c'est de la
décibilisation il s'agit pas un peu
d'aller comme d'habitude dans une
politique de la réaction facile mais
plutôt dans une politique de la
prévention active ce qui est pas le cas
pour vous c'est une réaction facile
c'est un mot lâché
de l'État est écoute humilié de formule
facile donc celle là ou une autre je
suis pas vraiment étonné
à Saint-Brevin on l'a vu la marche a eu
lieu à l'appel des personnalités de
gauche il y avait pas de monde des
républicains pas de monde de la majorité
présidentielle est-ce que du coup
c'était une marche politique hier
je crois que c'est que le choix qui a
été fait de la part des autres forces
politiques et regrettable soit on dit
que collectivement nous soutenons ce que
font les élus locaux et singulièrement
les mers et je pense que ça concerne
toutes les forces politiques
républicaines soit pas et essayer de
coller ça à une seule réaction des
forces de gauche c'est pas parce que
l'initiative est lancée par la gauche
que forcément elle est mauvaise parce
que en l'espèce elle concerne tout le
monde mais le maire lui-même a parlé de
récupération de l'extrême gauche il y a
pas eu de tentative de récupération j'ai
pas vous avez vu vous avez vu les images
vous avez vu que la plupart des grands
leaders nationaux sont restés comme cela
était dit d'ailleurs en retrait la
perspective c'est surtout de montrer à
un moment qu'il faut un coup d'arrêt à
la complaisance qui est réelle vis-à-vis
des débordements d'extrême droite en
France
qui se multiplie et qui sont un problème
majeur pour notre démocratie
il y a de la compétence du gouvernement
vis-à-vis de cette de cette extrême
droite on a la plupart du temps une
espèce de mise à l'écart et à discours
autour de l'ultra gauche mais en
revanche tout ce qui relève de l'extrême
droite et peut traiter par ce
gouvernement c'est pas traité de la même
façon pour vous l'ultra absolument pas
absolument pas parce que j'entends bien
que
dissocier les forces de gauche peut être
un objectif politique pour pour le
gouvernement puisque c'est la seule
vraie opposition à l'Assemblée nationale
mais ça risque permanent qui est celui
de légitimer l'extrême droite il y a
plein d'exemples en France il y a pas
que l'exemple de Saint-Brevin il y a
l'exemple des identitaires qui se
multiplient ou à ou à Lyon voir à
Bordeaux et ces problèmes spécifiquement
ne sont pas assez traités en tout cas
pas à la hauteur de ce que ça demande à
mon sens le maire de Saint-Brevin a dit
qu'il s'était senti abandonné par l'État
mardi le ministre de la Justice Eric
Dupond-Moretti qui a été auditionné par
le Sénat à Dinant à la justice n'a pas
abandonné le maire de Saint-Brevin
qu'est-ce que vous en dites
je dis quand même que moi j'ai entendu
j'étais à l'audition du maire de
Saint-Brevin et je vais vous dire il a
été doublement abandonné il a été
abandonné parce que
c'est l'ensemble de cette affaire c'est
en raison du déplacement d'un centre qui
accueille les migrants un cada et en
l'espèce habituellement contient un
accompagnement de l'État les choses
peuvent bien se passer c'est pas
exactement ce qui s'est passé du tout à
sa braisa il y a d'abord eu ça et
ensuite dans cet emballement
quand on voit la chronologie que nous
rappelle le maire de Saint-Brévin on se
rend bien compte que quand même à mon
sens en tout cas si j'avais été élu de
ce département j'aurais vraiment
souhaité beaucoup plus d'aide de la part
du sous-préfet et du préfet peut-être
que les autorités locales ont eu
l'impression de réagir mais cette
impression enfin la réaction n'est pas à
la hauteur de ce Corée exiger cet
emballement qui finit par un incendie
volontaire quand même des voitures qui a
une conséquence sur sa maison
enfin là il devait y avoir beaucoup plus
pour aider le maire et son équipe
municipale c'est une évidence vous allez
auditionner la semaine prochaine le
préfet et le sous-préfet de leur
Atlantique qu'est-ce que vous attendez
de cette édition
je vais à titre individuel je voudrais
juste savoir s'ils ont été à la hauteur
du poste qui est le leur et de ce qu'ils
sont censés faire alors je connais bien
le sujet des préfets et des sous-préfet
pour avoir travaillé dessus moi j'aurais
simplement savoir s'ils ont été à la
hauteur de ce qu'ils sont c'est-à-dire
des représentants de l'État et une
incarnation locale de l'État qui doit
faire en sorte justement que en ce qui
concerne l'ordre et la sécurité publique
et bien celle-ci ceci soit assurée
est-ce que vous allez vous envisagez
d'auditionner Gérald Darmanin par
exemple ou des membres du gouvernement
on va voir d'abord c'est d'abord c'est
un problème d'abord c'est un problème
local il faut donc continuer j'allais
dire à des idées le fil local et puis
après nous verrons si d'autres
investigations soient nécessaires mais
c'est quand même en première ligne au vu
de ce qui nous a été dit la question
effectivement du corps préfectoral local
et je crois que cet événement d'ailleurs
à étonné en tout cas c'est ce que je
sais beaucoup de leurs collègues dans
d'autres départements ça les interpelle
parce que pour encore une fois discuter
avec pas mal de préfets et de
sous-préfet ils sont vraiment très allez
on va le dire gentiment surpris de ce
qui s'est passé cette
annonce de la démission du maire de
Saint-Brévin Elizabeth borne la reçu et
la ministre des collectivités
territoriales a annoncé plusieurs
mesures renforcement des sanctions
pénales en pas de sécurité des référents
gendarmerie est-ce que pour vous ces
mesures sont à la hauteur
là encore une fois
ces mesures vont être utiles alors nous
aurions souhaité au parti socialistes
qui s'assoit encore plus important mais
on va pas on va pas dire on va pas dire
qu'elle je vais y revenir on va pas dire
qu'elle ne va pas dire qu'elle ne sont
pas nécessaires maintenant il faudrait
faire en sorte que on ne traite pas de
ces questions à chaque fois après il y a
des problèmes de violence vis-à-vis des
élus il y a des problèmes de dureté de
l'exercice des fonctions il y a des
problèmes pour trouver des élus en tout
cas pour faire en sorte que l'ensemble
des conseils municipaux soit complet
pour faire en sorte que l'on les garde
dans le temps pour faire en sorte que
les mères continuent à exercer leur rôle
dans le temps ça veut dire qu'il
faudrait prendre le problème du statut
de l'élu abra le corps ce n'est pas le
cas et c'est pour moi un regret profond
ça veut dire que le phénomène de
démission des lieux locaux re travailler
plus de 1200 d'émissions depuis les
dernières municipales pour vous va
continuer on n'arrive pas à enrayer ce
phénomène non on n'arrive pas à envoyer
ce phénomène alors le ministre nous dit
a raison que on est au même taux de
démission ce mandat que le mandat
précédent mais pour travailler par
ailleurs sur ce sujet ce qu'on ne voit
pas c'est que dans le même temps
progresse la démission des conseillers
municipaux et des adjoints qui elle
prend une tournure inquiétante
singulièrement pendant ce mandat donc on
voit bien qu'il y a un malaise si on
veut faire fonctionner la démocratie
locale si on veut que tout le monde est
une chance d'accès à cette démocratie
locale et puis s'exercer un poste local
il faut un statut de l'élu pas pour en
faire une caste à part pour faire en
sorte que on puisse avoir une démocratie
qui fonctionne et qui se donne sa chance
à chacun on va parler de la réforme des
retraites le 8 juin sera examiné à
l'Assemblée nationale la proposition de
loi du groupe yote visant à abroger
cette réforme des retraites mais une
bataille politique se joue déjà autour
de ce texte le débat aura-t-il lieu il y
aura-t-il un vote on va en parler avec
notre journaliste parlementaire Audrey
[Musique]
bonjour
et Audrey face à la proposition de loi
du groupe liotte qui vivent donc à
abroger la recul de l'âge de départ à la
retraite de 62 à 64 ans c'est défenseur
envisage d'activer l'article 40
qu'est-ce que c'est l'article 40 ans
c'est un article de la Constitution et
son but c'est d'éviter tout dérapage
financiers selon cet article les
propositions et les amendements des
parlementaires ne doivent pas diminuer
les recettes ou aggraver la charge
publique ou alors il faut que ce soit
compensé dans la foulée les défenseurs
de la réforme des retraites estiment que
si on abroge le texte on supprimerait
entre 12 et 18 milliards d'euros de
ressources sont tombés donc sous le coup
de l'article 40 alors pour l'instant le
texte suit son cours il a même été
accepté par le Bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale qu'il a jugé recevable parce
que les auteurs de la proposition
veulent compenser les pertes avec de
nouvelles taxes sur le tabac écoutez
Éric Coquerel c'est le président de la
commission des finances à l'Assemblée
une proposition loi elle est elle passe
d'abord au bureau de l'Assemblée le
bureau de l'Assemblée ou la majorité
comme vous le savez est majoritaire et
le bureau de l'Assemblée décide de la
recevabilité de ses lois y compris en
vertu du fameux article 40 donc de ce
point de vue là ça a été fait et madame
la présidente de l'Assemblée n'a pas
voulu revenir là-dessus malgré ce que
lui ont demandé certaines de ses amis
bien après il peut y avoir un recours
sur le président de la commission des
finances mais c'est pas le fait de
déclencher c'est pas automatique c'est à
recours que peuvent décider ou pas
certains députés le gouvernement etc en
l'occurrence ce recours il a été déposé
entre cette interview lundi sur votre
plateau et aujourd'hui
Eric Coquerel le président donc de la
commission des finances a été saisie par
la majorité présidentielle tout comme
Jean-René Cazenave le rapporteur général
qu'il a fait savoir dans une tribune au
Monde on leur demande de réexaminer donc
la proposition sur la base de l'article
40 en fait l'objectif pour les
défenseurs de la réforme c'est d'éviter
à tout prix que le texte soit examiné le
8 juin avec donc le risque d'être adopté
on le voit pour beaucoup de régions la
contestation et les manifestations
ont trouvé
un certain calme c'est cette proposition
de loi qui rejette de lui sur le feu on
fera tout pour que ce débat n'est pas
lui il est illégitime politiquement
techniquement et il met en danger à
nouveau nos finances publiques alors
enricoquerel appartient je le rappelle à
la France insoumise qui soutient la
proposition lot Jean-René Cazenave lui
fait partie de la majorité
présidentielle c'est finalement une
troisième personne il y a elle brûle
Pivet la présidente de l'Assemblée qui
pourrait être amenée à trancher et dans
une interview à la tribune elle n'exclut
rien Eric kerouge vous y croyez à
l'activation de l'article 40
avec ce gouvernement tout est possible
pour museler le Parlement et on l'a vu
pendant l'ensemble de l'examen du texte
mais croire que des procédures
techniques parce que c'est ça qu'on
utilise depuis le début vont empêcher à
la fois la frustration démocratique et
la colère
c'est une imbécilité forte la
déclaration que j'entends là selon
laquelle le débat serait légitime mais
en fait c'est cette réforme qui est
illégitime et quand on parle de 12 à 18
milliards d'économies on oublie que le
recul de 62 à 64 ans va générer en fait
entre 3 et 4 milliards de dépenses en
plus parce que ça va il y aura des
problèmes de santé des problèmes en
termes d'arrêt maladie etc donc du début
jusqu'à la fin on aura fait en sorte de
marcher sur un parlement où on n'a pas
la majorité c'est le cas je le rappelle
de
Emmanuel Macron et de son de son
gouvernement et donc le palliatif c'est
d'utiliser tous les moyens qui existent
au sein à la fois de la Constitution ou
du règlement des assemblées pour
j'allais dire museler artificiellement
les choses et pour vous sur le fond
c'est pas justifié cette proposition de
loi elle a alourdit pas la charge
publique elle alourdit pas les dépenses
il y a encore une fois il y a une
principe sain et ça a été dit il y a un
principe simple et vous l'avez répété
c'est que dans plein puisque
quoi qu'il arrive l'article 40 est une
limite très forte à l'activité
parlementaire depuis 1958 c'était
d'ailleurs le but de cet article et bien
depuis 1958 les parlementaires députés
sénateurs cherchent d'où qu'il soit de
quelques bords politiques qu'ils soient
à contourner l'article 40 notamment en
gageant le texte c'est-à-dire comme vous
l'avez dit on l'espèce engageant le
texte par une taxe souvent sur le
souvent sur le tabac il y a de multiples
textes qui ont été étudiés avec cette
modalité alors la question est toute
simple pourquoi ça a été possible sur
d'autres textes pourquoi on l'espèce ça
ne le serait pas ça ne sera pas parce
que encore une fois la majorité qui
pense avoir
gagné un peu de tranquillité risque de
la perdre à nouveau parce que le sujet
démocratiquement n'est pas tranché au
fond malgré toute l'apparence d'une
parfaite technicité et du respect de la
formalité des choses du coup vous croyez
un débat vous croyez un vote le 8 juin
vous pensez qu'au final il y aura un
honnêtement je doute profondément de la
volonté de la majorité relative d'aller
vers un débat un débat qui n'est pas
illégitime et un débat justement qui
quand il n'est pas tranché au Parlement
et trancher ailleurs mais est-ce que du
coup c'est un peu ce que dit aussi elle
brune Pivet est-ce que c'est pas un
problème pour le Parlement et pour la
crédibilité du Parlement d'avoir une
proposition de loi qui abroge un texte
qui vient tout juste d'être adopté alors
si c'est un problème pour le Parlement
de faire la loi et de la défaire dans ce
cas là il faut que Madame brun Pivet
change de fonction parce que encore une
fois ce café une loi une autre peut le
défaire et encore une fois le débat
parlementaire le débat démocratique ce
n'est pas l'unanimisme quand bien même
le gouvernement le souhaiterait l'autre
argument de la majorité présidentielle
c'est de dire que finalement cette
proposition liotte c'est une fausse
promesse puisque ensuite le texte sera
sûrement retoqué au Sénat qu'est-ce que
vous répondez là dessus c'est pas le
problème le problème c'est que il y a un
texte on le laisse cheminer et on verra
où il arrive la fosse promesse la fosse
province initiale c'est celle portée par
cette réforme qui est néfaste pour la
plupart des Français pour les plus
précaires et singulièrement pour les
femmes
c'est pas aussi une fausse promesse que
vous faites aux Français aux opposants
en tout cas cette réforme de leur faire
croire que ça peut être abrogé
excusez-moi le vous ne s'applique pas
parce que en l'espèce vous savez que
c'est une proposition du groupe liotte
et qui est assez loin à vrai dire en
général à gauche soutenu par la gauche
mais ce n'est pas une proposition de la
gauche mais il est il est fatal que nous
la soutenions puisque pour nous ça va
dans le bon sens celle d'une abrogation
mais encore une fois
encore une fois s'il y a un combat
politique sur un sujet en particulier il
est normal que l'opposition aussi se
saisisse de tous les moyens dont elle
dispose pour faire entendre sa voix
c'est aussi simple que ça
si jamais il y a un vote à l'assemblée
le 8 juin si jamais ce vote fait que le
texte est adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale que fera la gauche au Sénat
il y a une niche du groupe socialiste au
mois de juin est-ce que pour vous il
faut s'emparer du texte très vite ou
est-ce qu'il faut attendre la rentrée on
fera ce qu'il faut faire
c'est-à-dire très vite c'est-à-dire je
pense faire passer le texte il y a
différentes il y a différentes niches on
discutera entre nous mais
il faut continuer enfin j'entends encore
une fois que Emmanuel Macron et son
gouvernement va lui faire comme si tout
était bien passé d'ailleurs on l'a vu et
qu'il fallait passer à à autre chose
mais les Français ne passent pas à autre
chose parce que comme vous le savez
certains qui devaient certains et
certaines qui devaient partir à la
retraite commence à être impactés un peu
à la fois et tout le monde est en train
de prendre la dimension et la mesure de
ce que représente en fait la réforme
pour eux donc non le débat n'est pas
terminé
merci Audrey merci à tout à l'heure on
va parler logement avec vous logements
social quand et c'est très important
quand on sait qu'il y a plus de 2
millions de Français qui sont sur liste
d'attente pour le social ce sera à
suivre dans le club vous avez suivi une
audition au Sénat Audrey on va aller du
côté de chez vous dans le Sud-Ouest on
va aller voir Jefferson bonjour
Jefferson des sports merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous journaliste à sud-ouest
Jefferson et vous allez nous parler d'un
autre texte c'est le texte immigration
ce texte va donc revenir sur le tapis
alors je reviens pas sur les différents
revirements qui accompagnent ce projet
de loi depuis plusieurs mois erikao je
vous les avais suivis simplement la
droite y compris la droite sénatoriale a
battu ses cartes elle veut pouvoir
toucher à la constitution organiser des
référendums sur l'immigration et toucher
à la primauté des traités européens la
question est la suivante est-ce que vous
craignez une surenchère sur ce texte
on est on est littéralement dans la
démesure sur le texte de la part de la
part du groupe LR à l'Assemblée comme au
Sénat des mesures c'est à dire
la démesure dans tous les sens dans dans
tous les sens du terme on fait tout ce
qu'on peut et plus à vrai dire la droite
n'a plus de projet politique elle n'a
plus de projet social le seul projet
social c'est de reprendre et c'est assez
amusant d'ailleurs dans les enquêtes
d'opinion de reprendre les thématiques
qui sont celles du rassemblement
national une thématique de la droite
pour vous la lutte la lutte contre
l'immigration c'était une des
thématiques de la droite le problème
c'est que ça devient de fait la seule
thématique de la droite parce que on
voit dans certains sondages j'y
reviendrai que les Français peuvent être
en accord avec ces propositions mais
quand vous regardez et dans le même
temps la force politique dit qu'il doit
qu'il doit porter ses projets c'était
pas les républicains qui est choisi
c'est leur rassemblement national ce qui
fait que cette cette volonté de la
droite et à la fois incompréhensible et
ridicule
à droite ce qu'on oublie la droite je
voudrais juste préciser ça c'est que à
un moment donné et selon le les Français
peuvent réagir contre certains aspects
de l'immigration mais dans le temps dans
le temps et toutes les études le
montrent la tolérance vis-à-vis de
l'immigration et l'attitude par rapport
à l'immigration elle est plus positive
donc vous avez des variations fortes à
des moments donnés mais la tendance à la
à l'acceptation de l'Immigration et de
plus en plus forte c'est ça qui est
sidérant c'est de voir que comme on peut
pas se focaliser sur un projet social
parce que la droite n'en a plus qu'elle
s'est fait prendre son projet économique
par Emmanuel Macron elle se focalise sur
un seul point celui de l'immigration au
point d'ailleurs de rompre avec toutes
les boussoles qui ont été les siennes
dans le passé
j'ai personne voulu ajouter quelque
chose oui non est-ce que simplement ça
vous pensez encore qu'il y en aquare est
possible entre cette majorité
présidentielle relative et les LR à la
lueur de cette que vous constatez donc
à vrai dire c'est pas moi de C'est pas
moi c'est pas à moi de le dire mais je
pense que
vous savez dans quoi on est reparti ah
oui ça je vois à peu près bien dans quoi
on est reparti mais enfin les LR vont
pousser de plus en plus et de plus en
plus loin pour pousser le gouvernement
dans ces retranchements et l'Alliance
bancale qu'ils ont eu pendant les
retraites bancales parce qu'elle n'a pas
été complète à l'Assemblée nationale
d'où le 49.3 peut éventuellement se
recréer ou pas mais à vrai dire je pense
qu'il y a quand même une forme d'accord
minimale est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est un sujet qui peut
dijorité sénatoriale parce que là on a
vu la droite qui a proposé deux
propositions de loi et on voit que le
centre propre texte c'est un sujet de
division pour vous au sein de la
majorité écoutez s'il y a deux textes ça
veut dire quand même qu'il y a pas
uneanimité ou en tout cas que l'une des
composantes veut faire entendre
particulièrement sa voix en revanche je
crois pas qu'il y aura de dissonance à
l'intérieur du groupe LR ça c'est une
certitude entre la droite
faudra voir jusqu'où j'allais dire les
LR pousse le curseur et ça sera
difficile de le pousser plus loin
qui est dans les tuyaux c'est celle du
RSA oui simplement cette réforme du RSA
sera présenté en janvier en juin pardon
elle vise à rendre obligatoire 15 à 20h
d'activités d'insertion par semaine pour
les bénéficiaires est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à étudier cette mesure parce que
l'objectif annoncé est de les aider dans
leur retour vers l'emploi ou est-ce que
vous y voyez une nouvelle attaque contre
un public une population déjà fragile
je pense qu'il y a une incompréhension
profonde
des gens qui sont au RSA et en même
temps
il y a une stigmatisation de plus en
plus forte parce que il y a une
difficulté réelle pour les gens qui sont
juste simplement quelques heures de
grandeur le RSA pour une personne c'est
600 quelque chose 600 8 euros je crois
par
mois le taux le taux de pauvreté en
France c'est 1120 euros par mois et le
SMIC c'est 1300 1400 maintenant 1380
euros par mois ce que vous voyez en fait
c'est que les gens qui sont au SMIC sont
en fait dans une situation difficile et
que on choisit forcément dans ces cas-là
où on ne comprend pas forcément ce qui
arrive ce qui se passe en dessous parce
que on estime et à juste titre que quand
on travaille certains vivent des aides
des aides sociales le vrai problème
c'est donc le montant des salaires en
France qui est pas assez élevé qui
permettrait de répondre à certains
soucis mais le RSA c'est pas des gens
forcément qui sont immédiatement
mobilisables c'est des gens qui ont des
problèmes de logement des problèmes de
mobilité et souvent des problèmes de de
santé
c'est c'est toute l'histoire de la
transformation du RMI le revenu
municipal le revenu minimum d'insertion
en RSA le revenu de solidarité active et
effectivement il faut mieux les
accompagner mais pas en présentant les
choses
enfin dans la tonalité de l'énoncé que
vous avez donné
on voit autre chose on voit bien que on
essaye aussi dans l'intitulé de
stigmatiser un soi-disant assistanat
c'est ça le problème le problème de
l'accompagnement c'est une c'est une
évidence est-ce que font tous les
départements en matière de RSA et
d'ailleurs ils le disent merci Jefferson
la Une de Sud-Ouest combien coûte le
tour à Bordeaux c'est à la Une de votre
journal ce matin merci de Jefferson
d’espoir et merci beaucoup
Eric et merci de votre planète